one of the more frustrating parts of the
early game is just how quickly your
pockets will start to fill up with items
you'll be delighted to know that you can
purchase two upgrades to expand your
pockets after you've paid off your tent
i would recommend focusing on these two
upgrades you'll need to visit resident
services in the center of town and
access the computer kiosk in the corner
from here you can purchase a pocket
organization guide using nook miles five
thousand nook miles may seem expensive
but it's absolutely worth it the next
upgrade will be called ultimate pocket
stuffing and will cost 8 000 nook miles
again totally worth it trust me after a
few weeks with the game you'll have more
nook miles than you can possibly know
what to do with unless you want to go on
a crazy number of villager hunts which i
wouldn't blame you if you did after
those two upgrades you'll have four rows
with a total of 40 item slots